a man's shoe
a child's pink patterned winter coat
peek out from the black tarps that have
become funeral shrouds
this narrow 25 meter long trench is a
mass grave in the besieged city of
maripole the mayor says more than 1200
people have been killed there are no
basic services aid groups are warning of
a humanitarian catastrophe
the only thing i want is for this to be
finished i don't know who's guilty who's
right who started this damn them all
those people who started this
three more humanitarian corridors were
expected to open on thursday according
to the ukrainian government 35 000
people found safe passage on wednesday
but thousands more remain trapped
turkey hosted the highest level of talks
between russia and ukraine since the
invasion began
the foreign ministers of both countries
met in the city of antalya
russia did not commit to a ceasefire or
a humanitarian corridor in maripole
i
did my best to
at least
find
a diplomatic solution
we also raised the issue of a ceasefire
24-hour ceasefire
to
resolve the most pressing humanitarian
issues
we did not make progress on this
in the south of the country soldiers
fought in the street
in a suburb of the capital kiev
journalists reported intense fighting
overnight the ukrainian government says
russia continues to advance with the
goal of surrounding the capital
military
we don't want militarization of ukraine
you can do it even without nato we don't
want the preservation of the tendency to
create a neo-nazi state in ukraine of
course we want ukraine to be neutral
the u.n has now verified that 516
civilians have died since russia invaded
ukraine two weeks ago but says the
actual toll will be much higher
in myropol more burials are expected
so far 70 people some who died of
natural causes have now been laid to
rest in this mass grave inside one of
the small city's old cemeteries
natasha ghani al jazeera
hundreds of people on the outskirts of
kiev are trying to flee intense russian
shelling
people have been crossing a small river
in the district of europe to head into
the capital
the area has come under sporadic mortar
fire in recent days killing a number of
people many plan to go to kiev's railway
station to catch a train to the west of
the country
many people are living basements their
houses their apartments and try to live
from european from bucha and this is the
place where people are crossing the
bridge which is destroyed and from here
the evacuation starts
here territorial defense works a member
of territorial defense also so we're
helping people just to get to the cars
to buses and to move
let's bring in bart chefchick he is
visiting a senior fellow at the german
marshall fund and he joins us via zoom
from brussels
um
we just heard from kamala harris
speaking about the u.s commitment to
ukraine and to poland after it
refused uh to receive and then deliver
those polish jets to ukraine
my question for you is
what's your assessment of the american
response to what's happening in ukraine
well thank you very much for having me
look you've seen an incredibly unified
response within the whole nato alliance
within the whole free world and
responding to russia's aggression in
ukraine
through as pointed out swift and severe
sanctions are going to
inflict immense damage on russia's
economy uh the theory is to inflict
damage
on the economy to exert pressure on
putin regime to jesus course you've seen
25
nato allies and partners
announce or deliver military aid to
ukraine and this is serious
weaponry from anti-tank
weapons to
anti-aircraft missiles um rifles
ammunition and so forth
and uh we've also seen and this is
probably a little bit less visible
to the public but
you know this alliance management this
uh response by the whole free world
doesn't happen automatically it takes a
lot of behind the scenes effort and
consultation and planning
and in fact um the latest episode over
the fighter jets from poland to ukraine
illustrates the importance of
consultation and that behind the scenes
uh private discussion and coordination
and what's probably surprising is that
you haven't had more um sort of
incidents like this and in fact it's
been across the board unified response
in a very complicated situation
with all of that uh
equipment that you're talking about
there that's gone from europe and from
the u.s to
uh
ukraine how matched or otherwise are
russia's and ukraine's military on the
ground and also in the air
well
you know the assumption before february
24th was that
it would take anywhere between 24 to 72
hours for
ukrainian defense forces to fold against
uh russia's technologically advanced
military but in fact the ukrainian army
has
proven uh the that has the will to fight
it has the resolve and the ability to do
so and not only the defense forces but
of course you've seen these territorial
defense forces civilians volunteers
uh and across the ukrainian population a
unified response and commitment to
resist
now
the weaponry that's being delivered to
ukraine is important because uh
president zielinski has declared that
they will fight they will not surrender
they will fight uh until russia backs
down but they need the tools to do so
and in fact uh the west and the free
world at large has become the arsenal of
ukraine's democracy and resistance just
as uh america during world war ii was
the arsenal of democracy and helping the
uk and other
uh european allies resist uh nazi
aggression
all right thank you very much for your
time bart chef chick there visiting
senior fellow at the german martial fund
thank you very much
russia and ukraine have collectively
long been referred to as the breadbasket
of europe together they account for 30
of global wheat exports but the war in
ukraine is pushing up the price of grain
around the world especially in heavily
dependent regions like africa and the
middle east the united nations food and
agricultural organization says egypt
imports around 85 percent of its wheat
from the two warring sides
lebanon gets 81 percent of its wheat
from ukraine
other countries like iran libya and
turkey are also heavily reliant
food shortages could affect the lives of
millions of people particularly in
developing countries steep price
increases and basic necessities like
bread milk and meat can also produce
food insecurity famine and civil unrest
let's bring in abdullah abbasian he is a
food market expert and former senior
economist at fao and former g20
agricultural market information system
secretary that's a mouthful uh he joins
us via zoom from rome thank you for your
time um what's your assessment of what
this is going to mean
for those countries whose populations
already face food insecurity
unfortunately it's going to be more
difficult
you know the prices have been going up
for basically all basic foodstuffs uh at
least for a year
well before the current war uh the war
is just exacerbating the the pressure on
prices to go up further because you know
people naturally expect that the uh
there will be a shortfall
inevitabilities in the world market and
this will be seen in prices wheat for
example which is so important for middle
eastern north african markets have
gained something like 40 just recently i
mean this type of increase in such a
speed has taken everybody by surprise
and i'm afraid that many countries
around the world
are not prepared for that
and i was reading that some countries uh
traditionally have consumed a lot of
wheat because wheat
has been cheaper than protein so what do
you think this is going to mean for
people's health i mean longer term
well again going back to the kobe period
which still is with us by the way people
seem to forget that
we already have seen a huge increase in
the number of hungry and as well as huge
increase in malnourishment that means
you're not getting the kind of equality
food that you need this predates the war
now with these prices i'm just afraid
that not even bread may become
affordable in many places in the world
just
minutes ago in the us they came up with
the latest inflation
level it's a striking 7.9 percent year
on year fastest increase in 40 years and
we're talking here about highly
developed country united states so you
could just imagine
the pressure right now in many parts of
the world when it comes to inflation and
inflation is not just food it's energy
it's everything so this is also the
other thing that we have to really
really contemplate on we're not talking
about food in isolation
look at the fertilizer market look at
the energy market all these things come
together so the pressure on especially
the most vulnerable
i do not think has been greater than
this since the second world war
are there alternative sources i know
you're saying that it's not just about
wheat it has flow-on effects everywhere
but i guess my question is
is this shorter is this price increase
uh
caused by a shortage able to be easily
circumvented by planting more elsewhere
or like how long does it take to to make
up for that loss
i'm glad you asked this question because
it's very important if you look at the
short term prayers let's say between now
and the next big harvests in the
northern hemisphere talking about grains
as a matter of fact we shouldn't be so
worried about the shortage ukraine and
russia have already exported the bulk of
what they would have exported in the
current marketing season known as 20 20
21.
um there is probably like eight nine ten
million ton left to to be exported
before the next harvest and i don't
think that the rest of the world other
major exporters would not be able to
make up for that unfortunately though
the market doesn't look at this it
doesn't look at what is happening the
next two three months he's looking
beyond he's worried about planting the
spring plantings for next year is
worried about whether the fact in these
countries especially in ukraine i would
say there will be ordinary harvesting
that will take place and that next year
ukraine will be able to export or not or
how much of russian wheat will make it
to the world market this anticipation of
next year next season i would rather say
which is 20 20 23 season next season not
having as much as even this year is what
is fueling the price increase um it's
inevitable uh we're all humans we're all
worried about the future what do we do
we go and buy now we try to buy now and
there is a there is a bit of a
speculation there
which is also fueling so i'm very
worried about this because the prospects
do not look good but if you want to be
realistic we have to accept the fact
that today as we speak we do not have a
shortage what we have is lots of fear
and that fear has added is is the one
that drives on prices
all right hey thank you very much uh for
your time there abdul there's a abbasian
food market expert
thank you